foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
last Friday Bert Chrysler sold out
Amalie arena in his hometown of Tampa
Florida I was lucky enough to attend the
show live and given what a wild event it
was I thought it fully deserved its own
recap video right here on this channel
the tops off World Tour is truly unlike
any comedy experience you could possibly
find what could have been the greatest
night of your life last night up there
where would you rank it in the greatest
nights of your life so the greatest
greatest day of my life was my 40th
birthday
um I was in Australia I was the
skinniest I'd been as an adult and I was
working for Travel Channel I just signed
it like a two-year deal so I knew money
was coming in and Leanne was there
and I was playing at
um Bandai beach in the surf and it was
crystal clear and it was ice cold and
that I've always remember isolating that
as the greatest day of my life yeah
um yesterday beats it with a [__]
with a crocodile chasing it down the
road it is [__] yesterday was
phenomenal yeah now one of the many
things that made this show in particular
so special is that it took place in
Bert's Hometown you can tell the show
was extra special to him he even cried
when he walked out on stage for the
first time and again when he walked off
there were a lot of specific Tampa
references during the show like exact
street names which the crowd loved and
apparently this sold out show in Emily
Arena was the first time Bert's dad has
ever seen him do stand up which I think
is just insane we get back to the alien
and my parents show up cow head shows up
everyone starts showing up and I realize
the scope of it as I'm watching it fill
in my dad's never seen me do stand up
but in a weird way I'm oddly I had never
seen you do standing last time I was the
first time he's ever seen me do stand up
what the [__] is that crazy isn't that
[__] crazy why is that uh it makes
him nervous made him very nervous last
night he tried to get my mom to stop
recording my mom was recording me
walking on stage you're gonna get in
trouble you're gonna get us in trouble
my mom I was like we know the [__]
guy yeah yeah yeah we got a name as I
watched you guys progressively kill I
went oh this is a really hot room like
this is uh like they're like [__] at
it like they're like they're like dogs
chomping at the pit I get I'm so lucky
the way I get on stage because the way I
get on stage it makes you feel artistic
because they squat you down in the back
and and and you everyone else comes on
the side but they squat me down on the
back and I got JJ with me he's like you
ready boss man and I'm like yeah and
then I get to look up at the [__]
center of the Arena whatever Arena we're
at I can see it it's really a surreal
experience and then I hear Fortunate Son
I come out and I am Waterworks for like
[__] I mean honestly like probably a
solid minute and a half I killed a beer
I throw my shirt off I I'm I'm they're
just cheering and then and then this
will make me emotional I just go it's
good to be home and the place goes
no you got a second Standing Ovation you
get a standing ovation when you walked
on and then they sat down and they said
that and they stood up again yeah and
then I was like I gotta disconnect from
my emotions yeah because I'm not gonna
get through this set and from that
moment honestly until the
from that moment for 20 minutes I don't
remember a thing I don't remember a
thing I just remember everything was
hitting so hard I'm like I can't I'm not
gonna be able to follow this I'm not
gonna be able to follow what I'm doing I
gotta slow this energy down besides the
homecoming angle the other thing that
made this show so memorable was the
sheer amount of production Bert's been
putting into these Arena gigs we're
talking about two huge vertical video
screens on stage instead of the overhead
Jumbotron a light sound setup that looks
like it's for music festivals and an
endless amount of fog being pumped in
behind him throughout the show when all
of that comes together into one the view
of Brent on stage performing in front of
his hometown crowd was just tremendous
Joe I got your video Bert I hate to do
this man but
my tour bus is better than yours again
I went all black on them this time all
right Bert good luck man dude badass
tour bus here's my tour bus
we got it wrapped oh by the way here's
my other tour bus that's for my crew oh
this is one of my semis that carries my
stage here's another semi
that carries my audio equipment here's
my other semi
that carries all my video equipment but
badass tour bus bro all right we'll see
you guys in Tampa
Family Arena Baby by the end of the
night the show itself turned into just a
cherry on top which is pretty funny Greg
fit Simmons Mark Smalls and David
Williamson opened the show Bert was
electric on stage I think he chugged
like nine beers at one point we were all
just singing the National Anthem during
the show Bert shows and Bert fans are a
lot of fun thank you
[Music]
at one point he told a joke about Tom
and Christina and the whole place lost
their minds you could feel the venue
shaking to the core this material comes
out on Netflix as a special on March
14th and I really hope he keeps that
joke in there the exact same way
[Music]
[Applause]
Mars 14 2023
ladies and Gentlemen
by far the coolest moment of the night
happened during the machine story of
course burrow was about halfway through
telling his famous story when he went
off on a tangent about how grateful he
was to Tampa and the State of Florida
for the impact that they've had on his
career he then talked about how his new
movie The Machine is coming out soon and
told a funny story about being on the
phone with Sony asking them if he could
show the trailer to all his fans in
Tampa somebody's saying no Bert we have
millions of dollars invested in this
trailer coming out next week and Bert's
saying okay well what if you just send
it to me so I can show my mom and dad
Sony said yes apparently and then Bert
turns to the whole Arena and says okay
everyone except for my parents close
your eyes it was awesome to be in there
for that sneak peek it was obviously
very funny he got permission to show us
that but it was funny how he set it up
it was awesome to be in there during the
sneak peek and the movie looks [__]
awesome seven years ago one incredible
story blew up the internet when I was 22
I got involved with the Russian mafia I
was a frat boy on a class trip this is
Igor he's here for your protection he's
very dangerous and we're not to talk to
or hang out with him all I want to do is
hang out with him I did not speak
Russian
all I knew how to say was
it was literally the best summer of my
life we robbing this guy
23 years after those events
the story continues what is wrong with
this shirt
yeah machine not today brother not today
my dad showed up you paid money to see
my son tell his made-up story about
robbing a train for the million times
it's a true story it took about two
seconds before he started making me
mental look at it over there he's a
monster
are you the machine ma'am the party's
outside 23 years ago he was told the
only thing my father ever cared about
sorry this is some sort of tick-tock
prank I'm about to lose my [__] it's
definitely a prank clearly that's a fake
gun
or not they're coming with me back to
Russia
he's going down what's up why are you
talking about fast like hero speed or
something if I'm on speed oh more drugs
bird ah take off that shirt and show
those sobs who you really are now you
gotta party with me
he's the [__] machine
[Music]
overall actually going to this show was
a blast this is my first time ever
attending any sort of Bert Kreischer
event and I have to say it lived up to
all of the hype it was like a whole
experience built around a comedy show
where the jokes although funny aren't
even necessarily the most important part
of the night if the tops off world tours
headed to a city near you I would
definitely recommend Gathering a bunch
of people specifically ones that you
know like to drink get together get
hammered and go check it out for
yourself if that doesn't sound fun to
you you can save yourself The Hangover
and watch Bert's new special Razzle
Dazzle only on Netflix beginning March
14th
foreign
[Music]